[Musique]
le nom est un marqueur essentiel de
l'identité
c'est vrai pour les noms propres je suis
assez content du mien je remercie mes
parents
gilles renvoie au bouclier d'athéna qui
servit à percer pour vaincre l'infâme
gorgone méduse le nom du projet dont je
vous parle et demos ce qui est à la fois
un acronyme dispositif d'éducation
musicale et orchestrale à vocation
sociale
une référence à l'antiquité grecque et
bien sûr à la démocratie le projet demos
donne l'occasion à des enfants qui
vivent dans des quartiers populaires de
découvrir collectivement la musique
classique
on comprend tout de suite qu'il se passe
quelque chose d'inhabituel
les mots classique et populaire servant
d'ordinaire à former des catégories
distinctes art classique s'oppose à art
populaire et c'est particulièrement vrai
lorsqu'il s'agit de musique et pourtant
voilà que ces enfants qui vivent dans
des quartiers populaires populaire est
un des noms qu'on utilise c'est sûrement
le plus neutre
on en utilise d'autres qui sont beaucoup
plus maîtrisé intellectuellement comme
concentrant des difficultés sociales ou
clase politique de la ville et on en
utilise parfois qu'ils sont réellement
stigmatisant comme en difficulté
difficile sensible
pourtant voilà que ces jeunes jouent du
mozart du haydn du veto avec eux pour
cela il utilise des flûtes des violons
des violences elles ou encore des deux
des pianos n'ont pas de piano et qui
sont vaincus qui s'occupe de ce projet
eh bien c'est la philharmonie de paris
quand on vient de parler qui est l'un
des emblèmes du prestige et de
l'excellence musicale dans notre pays
et pourquoi quel est le sens de cette
action
lorsqu'on fait référence à l'antiquité
grecque
il faut être capable de répondre à la
question sinon socrates risque dans son
2 sur 9 us quai je vais donc vous parler
de deux sens et je vais essayer de
commencer de répondre à la question en
vous racontant une histoire l'histoire
d'un jeune garçon il est moins jeunes
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle sa carrière
zakaria fait partie de ces enfants que
l'on qualifie d' agiter ou de difficile
je tiens à vous dire que dans les
quartiers populaires dont il est
question
les enfants agités et difficile ne sont
pas si nombreux que cela et qu'on peut
même distinguer souvent chez eux une
capacité à s'enthousiasmer
en écoutant la ronde des princesses de
stravinsky largement supérieur aux
réactions que peuvent avoir les enfants
vivant dans les quartiers disons
classique et qui sont souvent prennent
souvent un air blasé
parce que ils prennent souvent un air
blasé mais à carriet très difficile
zakaria manqué d'attention il perturbé
la concentration de ses camarades et il
avait des gestes brusques qui ont
conduit dans les trois années où il a
participé au projet il y est entré à
l'âge de 10 ans il est resté jusqu'à 13
ans et ce qui était prévu et bien à
kariat a réussi à casser deux
violoncelles pendant ce projet l'un des
musiciens qui est devenu un ami
aujourd'hui l'un de ses musiciens 10ème
et mais qu'est ce qu'il fait là
gilles fait le sortir du projet soit
possible il ne il manque d'attention il
s'intéresse pas aux ni aux autres ni à
la musique c'est évident qu'il ne faut
pas qu'il reste le directeur du centre
social dans lequel zakaria été inscrits
me disais exactement le contraire
il est devenu un ami aussi aujourd'hui
et il me disait gilles il faut qu'il
reste c'est la première fois que je vois
zakaria suivre une activité de manière
assidue
il ne manque aucune séance il est
toujours à l'heure il se passe quelque
chose alors je me suis rendu compte que
ça aurait été un échec du projet une
défaite absolue si zakaria en était
sorti donc il est resté et pour l'aider
pour l'accompagner nous avons fait appel
aux services d'une musicothérapeute
italienne qui vit à paris et qui
brillamment l'a aidée à progresser à
changer de comportement a gagné en
attention et et oui ça commençait à
marcher mais voilà nouvel obstacle une
émission de télévision sur une grande
chaîne nationale à 52 minutes
quelle chance et bien pendant ces
cinquante deux minutes
zakaria a été la figure négatifs du
projet ça marquer les limites de nos
capacités d'inclusion par la musique
quatorze réflexion négative comptez part
comptabilisés par nous sur l'ensemble de
ses apparitions dans le documentaire est
à l'opposé un autre garçon qui lui a
fait l'objet de commentaires tous
positifs noir beau sage jouant de la
trompette et évidemment à qui on compare
un noir qui joue de la trompette et
bahamas davis quand ils ont pas
trompette ils ont sens du rythme il
paraît donc je vous laisse imaginer la
tête de zakaria lorsqu'il a vu le film
parce qu'il l'a vu le film bien
évidemment mais par chance tout s'est
bien terminé comme les belles histoires
puisque la communauté éducative qui
étaient autour de lui a fait en sorte
qu'il aille jusqu'au bout du projet est
lié à l'est de manière tellement
positive qu'à la fin du projet l'a
déclaré dans un documentaire que nous
avons réalisés nous mêmes il a déclaré
j'aurais fait quelque chose de bien dans
ma vie j'aurais joué du violoncelle
il n'a pas fait que ça de bien dans sa
vie zakaria aujourd'hui 16 ans et lamy
directeur de sang social dont je vous ai
parlé m'a dit clairement qu'il était
parfaitement intégrée dans la vie du
quartier et qu'il s'impliquait dans la
vie associative notamment via le centre
social en question un seul décrocheurs
vous manque et tout la démocratie est
perturbé voilà pourquoi il ne fallait
pas exclure un carriole je vais
continuer de répondre à cette question
du sens dans le projet demos vous parle
en vous racontant un peu ma vie en
parlant de mon parcours personnel suis
entré très vite dans un parcours de
pédagogue de la musique mais je ne
savais pas clairement ce qui m'animait
je savais pas exactement pourquoi je
faisais ça et je pense que le moment de
révélation fin du mois je m'en souviens
comme ça sur cette question du sens est
venue d'un cours
à l'université paris xiii où le
compositeur ahmed essyad nous a fait
entendre une pièce de rudes qui est le
catalan luth oriental
j'écoutais cette pièce je comprenais pas
tout j'étais moi-même guitariste de je
jouais beaucoup de guitare de jazz à
l'époque et en l'entendant je me disais
ça ressemble à quelque chose que je
maîtrise ça ressemble au langage que
j'utilise pour jouer de la musique mais
ce n'est pas exactement la même chose
est ce que je ne comprenais pas renforcé
le sentiment d'émotion que j'avais en
écoutant la pièce et ce jour là je crois
que c'est clairement ce jour là que j'ai
écrit dans ma tête
un principe qui a guidé je crois toute
ma carrière ensuite les êtres humains
sont avant tout semblable mais ils ont
la capacité de varier à l'infini sur les
mêmes fondamentaux
et pour illustrer sa je devais de le
faire très rapidement sans micro j'ai
amené un instrument de musique je vais
les chercher là juste derrière qui est
un instrument qui a traversé l'histoire
et vous allez comprendre que vous allez
m'entendre leur en faire la
démonstration sont juste des gestes pour
que je ne joue pas vraiment mais pour
vous compreniez le principe il ya un
lien très fort entre le langage
l'émotion et la capacité de transfert
dans ce qu'il ya dans l'être humain et
ce geste datent d'entre 10 et 20 mille
ans je vous montre
il surgit par mira
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai acquis la conviction que
l'éducation artistique est absolument
essentiel au développement des individus
mais c'est non seulement ça mais je
crois aussi qu elle est absolument
indispensable pour favoriser une
éducation à l'altérité au respect de
l'altérité
ça fait à peu près 35 ans que je tourne
autour de cette idée et au début je me
trouvais génial parce que je croyais que
j'ai trouvé un truc formidable et en
fait c'est un truc formidable mais je me
suis rendu compte que j'étais loin
d'être le seul à avoir regardé les
choses de cette manière
je me suis penché par exemple sur tous
les penseurs humaniste qui mettait cette
question d'éducation artistique au coeur
de la formation d'acier d'un jeune
citoyen donc c'est le cas des penseurs
des lumières bien évidemment des
penseurs comme tagore qui est un grande
figure de l'inde du début du xxème
siècle un peu éclipsé par gandhi et
c'était un philosophe un écrivain poète
compositeur il est l'auteur de l'hymne
bengale l hymne indien et il était
également danseur voilà et on trouve les
mêmes principes éducatifs
c'est aussi dans les écrits de john duty
et de ses successeurs qui ont
profondément marqué le système éducatif
américain est aujourd'hui c'est courant
humaniste
représente la voie de la résistance aux
sirènes obscurantiste et alarmistes
contemporaine donc je me réfère à ces
courants de pensée est pour moi le
projet demos a pour but de protéger
l'humanité oui j'y vais carrément quand
j'ai prononcé cette phrase devant des
collègues monique y va un peu fort but
de protéger l'humanité en contribuant à
réduire le nombre de ceux qui pensent
qu'un être humain peut être inférieure
et qui peuvent aller jusqu'à vouloir
l'éliminer de la surface de la planète
mais au contraire d'augmenter le nombre
de ceux qui sont capables de déceler le
semblable dans un autre être humain et
qui font de cela quelque chose qui les
habitent en permanence dans toute leur
vie sociale
c'est pourquoi il est important dans des
projets éducatifs que comme celui que je
je je mène que les enfants puissent se
rendre compte
même si l'or le répertoire privilégié et
la musique classique que à quel point
l'homme et musiciens donc nous
introduisons dans leur programme des
références à la musique de l'inde où ou
à la musique du monde arabe
pas pour l'éclectisme mais pour cette
idée rendez vous compte à quel point
l'homme est musicien et à quel point
nous sommes des êtres humains c'est
vraiment ce qui nous habite en
permanence mais le fait que ce soit de
la musique classique
à l'intérieur deux pros du projet demos
est aussi quelque chose de fondamental
parce que pour en revenir à zakaria aux
enfants et aux familles de ces quartiers
populaires très souvent lorsqu'ils
abordent cette musique
ils se disent ce n'est pas pour nous
est ce ce n'est pas pour nous peut très
bien se transformer en le nous contre
eux qui contrecarrait tous les espoirs
que nous entretenons ici avec tous ces
projets qui mettent en valeur le vivre
ensemble
[Applaudissements]